Christina Applegate opens up about her
life with multiple sclerosis and why it
was important to finish her part on dead
to me how do I deal with everything in
life
um I take I try to be really present
that's that's uh and grateful present
and grateful in a New York Times
interview which the actress says marks
the first time anyone has seen her
physical state she reveals that she put
on 40 pounds and has to walk with a cane
Christina was diagnosed with Ms in the
summer of 2021 in the middle of filming
the final season of her hit Netflix
series but the Anchorman star recalls
signs she previously missed indicating
that something wasn't right like when
she filmed a dance sequence in season
one where she felt a bit off balance
[Music]
she says at that moment quote I wish I
had paid attention but who was I to know
fast forward to August 2021 and
Christina publicly revealed her Ms
diagnosis in a tweet writing in part
it's been a strange Journey but I have
been so supported by people that I know
who also have this condition Christina's
Health halted production for several
months as she sought treatment and for
the actress taking that break was
difficult but important quote I needed
to process my loss of my life my loss of
that part of me so I needed that time
but she also admits it's hard to accept
her new reality although it's not like I
came on the other side of it like woohoo
I'm totally fine acceptance no I'm never
going to accept this I'm pissed as for
why Christina was determined to finish
filming dead to me well it was all for
Creator Liz Feldman and her friend and
co-star Linda Cardellini
cute I love you too you guys want to
dance oh my god do you see that we're in
the middle of something here read the
room
I had an obligation to Liz and talinda
to our story the powers that be were
like let's just stop we don't need to
finish it let's put a few episodes
together I said no we're going to do it
but we're going to do it on my terms we
both have the same kind of sense of
humor and I that it was at lunch we just
I think we I remember we looked at each
other at one moment and it was like I
know you I got you and so that was
before we shot and then we sat down and
started doing the scenes and they just
happen and it's like such a gift for me
Christina recently shared a photo of her
walking sticks as she prepares to
promote the series's third and final
season which hits Netflix November 17th
you're the best friend I've ever known
the best person I've ever known
and we survived because we had each
other as for Christina's other co-star
James Marsden he told E.T last month
he's simply in awe of her strength it
was a challenge but she's a warrior and
she just hit it head on and she's she's
working through it and you know there
was there were moments where we'd know
what it was before she was diagnosed and
and just all just very concerned for her
but she's you know she's a battler and
she you know she's getting through it
and uh but uh it was it was the the show
took a backseat to her health for sure
so um but we're all there just
surrounded surrounding her and giving
her the you know the best wishes the
best love and yeah but she's a tough one
she really is
foreign